[Music]
today I'm Eddie and I'll tell you what
there's nothing better than seeing your
friends acknowledged for the
contributions they make in your school
and community and there is a way to
recognize them it's called Ossie of the
month so I am saying awesome job good on
you and you're amazing every month kids
in schools across Australia are being
celebrated students just like you you
strive to see their school yard and
community be the best place it can be
because I being a great role model to my
class I've got the Aussie of the month
because I smiles and make other people
smile also owes you the most because
each Saturday I go to the aged care
facility on Euston Road to play the
piano I'm making people smile because it
makes me feel happy and grateful about
them all the other months means that you
can be a role model and show leadership
to your younger kids the best part of
ossie of the month is a students all
around Australia are being recognized
for helping others it creates a real
sense of pride in schools and
communities so miss Payne what is Aussie
other month mean to you to me Aussie of
the month means being an active member
of the community really engaging in all
of those different community aspects
looking after the school for people in
it as part of the civics and citizenship
curriculum strand it ties him really
well to what we do at this school as
well it was a great honor to air this
award if I felt very proud as I heard of
my friends cheering for me and when I
was here at the month I was surprised
when I was
I thought excited I couldn't believe it
that I did so well I had a little pride
and then I realized what I did to get
the award I felt really really excited
and proud celebrating the values of make
sure respects inclusion and fair good
means any one of you can be Ozzie of the
Month
makeup is respect matchup is when you
listen to others being kind and not
being rude and just being truthful it
means to have a good match for your size
and have fun whether you nominate
someone or nominated yourself it's a way
for everyone to show their pride in the
people make the school yard a community
a better place it's in this pain what
does that mean to you
respect to me means looking after
everyone making sure everyone is okay to
treat others nicely how you would treat
someone in your family how much I
respect it I don't leave people out to
include others and treat them how you
would want to be treated no means you
have a try
when you employ people it doesn't just
make them feel good it also makes you
feel really happy to include people and
help them when they need help all the
other month is about being a good friend
being fair and helping others it's about
celebrating our diverse communities and
maybe sure everyone is included
[Music]
for more information and to register
your school for this free program visit
Ozzie of the month org dot a you
[Music]